do you think Lisa's really done I don't
know I don't know I'm usually done for
now
so you think she'll be back I don't know
I think you never know how are you guys
you have a message for her um to have a
message for her you know I always wished
Lisa the best you know I know that you
know she may not feel that you know
because of everything that's gone on
this season I don't know just say yes I
did something if I didn't do it
I feel like Hunger to fight you sitting
here to tell me I am a liar but I have a
lot of respect for Lisa I care about her
very much you know we had a lot of fun
together and I really wish her the best
I think she's amazing at what she does
with her restaurants and the bars so I
wish her continued success and health
and happiness and love you've always
taken a high road well that's how I
really feel so hopefully that's the high
road because if I felt otherwise it
would be a very low road maybe but
that's how I really feel what is to come
the rest of the season um you know
there's just a lot of going on with the
women in our relationships and the show
is really strong still you know we're
going in it's our ninth year and the
ratings are really high and you know
people have been following you know our
lives for a really long time and I think
this is a crazy crazy season and if you
know it's kind of crazy to the very end
that ends on a crazy note - how was the
reunion brutal if I had to pick the one
word I have to say riddle it's the worst
it's like I mean whoever came up with
that is really I need to find out who
that was because this really tortures
for everybody
not for us for us it's great if we get
answers we were I mean it was the
longest reunion we've ever shot so it
was I mean you know it's like it's not
fun to do that and even though there's a
lot of women that are getting along and
are very close right now there's also a
lot of other stuff going on obviously oh
yeah I've said sometimes I didn't trust
you I didn't know where you were getting
all this money from why are you talking
about people want to know what I know no
one wants to relive it but do you ever
think about saying goodbye to the show
oh of course we all do really that's why
I say just seeing that you never know
are you coming back next season are you
thinking of that far hey I don't know I
just don't know yet I mean honestly each
year you think I mean could I really
hang in there another year but there's a
lot of fun we have to you know I think
you've seen on the show this season even
though the word drop it was drama there
was also a lot of fun I mean last
episode was crazy crazy ridiculous
get down go okay really embarrassing but
you know hey I made it nine years
without making that big of a fool out of
myself but whatever we live and learn
for a year we're celebrating the cast of
the hills in a way do you feel like the
hills is responsible for the reality TV
phenomenon I'm you know I was just
actually sitting with Kris Jenner in
favor Isaac we were talking about the
whole reality TV phenomenon I mean yes
they're a part of it The Osbournes were
part of it Paris and the simple life
all of that no so I mean we're on our
ninth years really crazy to think you
know that you know reality television
goes back even more than that it's
already like a lifetime
[Music]